[Rires]
[Musique]
Public Sénat avec le soutien de Mutualia
la mutuelle des territoires vous
présente manger c'est voter
[Musique]
bonjour les amis bienvenue à manger
c'est beauté nous sommes dans le
vignoble bordelais nimbé de l'or du
soleil vieux bordelais qui est le
premier employeur de la Gironde on va
visiter ensemble aujourd'hui un soleil
nous réchauffe peut-être trop pour les
raisins ce matin c'est différent c'était
les brumes de la Garonne
[Musique]
alors on est sur la Gironde et j'ai
rendez-vous avec Nathalie Delattre
sénatrice de Gironde vice-présidente du
Sénat qui va me faire découvrir son beau
département et les gens qui l'anime
bonjour madame la sénatrice bonjour
Vincent merci de m'accueillir bienvenue
à bord et à Bordeaux
donc Bordeaux est de plus en plus tourné
vers la Garonne oui tout à fait ça a été
un des enjeux de la renaissance de
Bordeaux vu par Alain Juppé et ce matin
on est dans une brume qui sent un petit
peu la fumée le charbon de bois quand
même oui nous avons des reprises de feu
malheureusement on a connu ça tous les
thés et on est encore sur une saison où
nous avons
à faire face à ces problématiques alors
natives de région parisienne tout de
suite parti en Aquitaine dans le
Périgord oui j'avais trois ans quand mes
parents ont décidé de déménager pour se
rapprocher du travail de mon père qui
était représentant dans ce secteur et ma
maman femme de ménage les études en
revanche direction Bordeaux oui des
études de droit qui
m'ont en Gironde et ensuite à
m'installer dans cette merveilleuse Bill
préfet du droit pour rentrer dans la
police et en fait je suis effectivement
rentrée en politique j'étais assistante
parlementaire et ensuite j'ai eu
différentes missions dans tes
collectivités territoriales locales pour
assister des politiques il y a toujours
une transmission verticale dans ce monde
de la politique donc certainement des
gens qui ont marqué votre carrière et
votre jeunesse alors j'ai commencé en
Dordogne avec Yves Guéna et puis je suis
arrivée ici j'ai rencontré Jacques
Chaban-Delmas mais j'ai aussi rencontré
le parti radical valoisien à l'époque
ensuite rencontrer Jean-Louis Borloo et
qui m'ont mis puis à l'étrier pour me
dire tu es assez porté les valises des
autres il faut maintenant que tu joues
un rôle de premier programme c'est ça et
du coup Alain Juppé m'a tendu cette main
il m'a proposé de le rejoindre dans son
équipe en 2008 et vous avez été mer
adjointe et on va d'ailleurs là vers
votre zone de Bordeaux oui qui
s'appelait avant le quartier Bordeaux
Nord et qui a été rebaptisé le quartier
Bordeaux maritime justement en l'honneur
du fleuve et de cette renaissance et
alors on voit émerger deux piliers un
peu comme le pont de Londres mais de
façon plus moderne c'est le pont qui
porte le nom d'un de vos mentors
nous sommes presque la dernière
destination à accueillir des pots de
croisière jusque dans son centre-ville
la politique est une chose très
importante dans votre vie il y a une
chose aussi qui prend une place
prééminente le vin d'ailleurs on m'a dit
que vous aviez un diplôme de
dégustatrice effectivement j'ai passé le
diplôme universitaire d'aptitude à la
dégustation
qui est décerné par la fécité de
Bordeaux et qui m'a permis de pouvoir
assembler nos vins à la propriété
j'espère qu'on va lever nos verres plus
d'une fois aujourd'hui au cours de ce
périple
vous sauverez un viticulteur alors
Nathalie Delattre vous avez toujours été
une centriste le portefeuille à droite
le cœur à gauche
en fait je suis et de droite et de
gauche d'un côté aujourd'hui ce qui crée
la valeur ajoutée de la France ce sont
les entreprises mais tout ça peut être
très précaire et du jour au lendemain on
peut se retrouver dans des situations
difficiles et donc il faut savoir
mettre en place des amortisseurs sociaux
et en fait la politique c'est de trouver
le juste milieu entre les deux
entendre aujourd'hui et de penser que le
gaullisme social le perdu
allez direction le Bassin d'Arcachon où
nous attend Olivier un ostréiculteur
très engagé puis Saint-Loubès ou
Emmanuel Favre la mère de la commune se
bat pour que ça continue de l'école soit
la plus locale et puis on rencontrera
Florian un jeune chef reconverti dans le
maraîchage où il y a tout juste un an et
Cédric éleveur du fameux agneau de
Pauillac qui a développé en plus une
activité fromagère et viticole pour
arriver à s'en sortir enfin direction la
cuisine de Thierry Renou chef étoilé qui
nous prépare une recette 100% girondine
en route
[Musique]
donc en fait faut pas qu'à 8 sont
vraiment en face de la dune du Pilat on
peut pas faire plus près
Olivier
qui travaille sur cette parcelle on va
dire sur ce banc sur le hamburgien
l'ensemble des osseurs du bassin
d'Arcachon une parcelle et sur le Bassin
d'Arcachon on est à peu près 300
exploitants
agriculteurs 300 entreprises on produit
entre 10 et 15000 tonnes et vitre par an
ce qui amène une vraie valeur économique
pour le territoire mais c'est une forte
valeur
identitaire et patrimoniale quoi
l'ostriculture sur le Bassin d'Arcachon
et d'une des plus vieillesse cultures en
France
[Musique]
ça ce sont des cages de profonde dans
cette culture c'est un métier très
difficile journée
chaque poche fait entre 10 et 15 kg là
l'avantage à ça c'est qu'en fait on
descend pas dans la mer ce sont les
cages qui viennent à bord du bateau à
l'aide de la grue ça a été inventé ici
ça ouais ouais tout à fait l'idée c'est
de faire aussi évoluer le métier parce
que ce métier on dit souvent les jeunes
ils foutent rien ils veulent pas
travailler c'est faux les jeunes ils
veulent travailler
jeunes pousses et c'est ce qu'on vient
rechercher ici on voit on est parti
d'une huître qui avait cette taille et
tout ça c'est de la nouvelle pousse
c'est quoi le chimiquement comme
substance la guerre c'est du calcaire
comme le marbre comme les falaises c'est
du calcaire nous on est sur un produit
100% naturel on est bio par nature on ne
peut vous proposer que ce que la nature
nous offre quoi c'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment donné s'il y a de bonnes
conditions alors évidemment il faut la
mettre de l'homme il faut qu'on les
travaille bien il empêche que c'est
quand même la nature qui fait 60% du
travail quoi alors attention c'est pas
un vrai couteau à huîtres non non
on l'envoie les huîtres elles ont
quasiment pondu donc ça c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle pour nous ce quand elles
sont très laiteuses qu'elles sont en
phase de ponte à travailler c'est
compliqué elles sont très fragiles très
vulnérables moi j'ai appris à les ouvrir
pour pouvoir les déguster parce que un
des freins effectivement à la
consommation des huîtres c'est ça
l'ouverture
il arrive
mais par contre moi je leur dis
aujourd'hui
ça me saoule de voir les huîtres mal
ouvertes je supporte pas avec des petits
bouts de coquille dedans etc
[Musique]
le moindre petit morceau de coquille